بعد الان من امام منزل عائله شقيرات في
جبل المكبر في القدس المحتله مراسلات
والجزيره وجد وقفي اذن فمكنت من الوصول
الى البيت وانتم الان وسط الركام همم ما
الذي جرى بتحديد ما هو مبرر او ذريعه
سلطات الاحتلال لهدم لهذا البيت
همم
نحن الان في جبل المكبر فوق منزل عائله
راتب محمد
الشقيرات هنا في جبل المكبر كان منزل نحن
الان نقف فوق ركام ذكريات اطفال وكبار
كانوا يقتلوننا في هذا المنزل 13 فردا
كانوا يقتلونا المنزل همم ثمانيه هم راتب
شقيرات صاحب المنزل وايضا ابنه وزوجه ابنه
وكذلك همم اخت همم شقيقه
صاحبه المنزل ايضا وهي زوجه اسير محرر اذا
السكان الاصليون المنزل ثمانيه مع ضيوفهم
زوجه الاسير الذي يقع في السجون
الاسرائيليه الان
اذا الاعداد الاجمالي هو ثلاثه عشر شخصا
ااه المنزل كان مكون من طابقين وقد بني في
عام
10 تم هدمه من دون ابلاغ العائله
بتاريخ الهجم من دون اخطار العائله قامت
قوات الاحتلال باقتحام المنزل وقد كان فيه
اطفال ونساء في داخل المنزل صاحب المنزل
لم يكن موجوده ابلغنا بانه كان في العمل
وصاحب المنزل هو محمد شقيرات راتبرات
موجود معنا الان اخ راتب همم يعني لا اعلم
ماذا اقول لك تم هدم المنزل امام عينيك
شعورك وهو يتم هذا المنزل الذي يقويك انت
واطفاله الحمد لله على كل حال احنا
بالنسبه
لفلسطين والقدس
ان شاء الله يعني لما الواحد يهدم بيته
يعني كانه طلع قطعه من قلبه او القلب
شو بدنا نكون حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل وبضل
نحنا الحمد لله رب العالمين
صامدينه وان شاء الله الى زوال الاحتلال
[موسيقى]
يعني هل تم اقتحامه دون ان يبلغوا اهل
البيت بانهم في طريقهم الى هدم المنزل
فقلت اليوم قواتنا هايله وكام وفي اللي
كانوا فيهم هو المنظر الي بيحكي يعني
الاثاث الاغراض الاطفال اغراضكم
اشياء فاضيه
تقريبا
قبل المره هذه مو اول مره وعندي قرار لهدم
هذا اللي هو في عنده قرارات
لمنزل لك خلال 30 عاما راتب شكرا جزيلا لك
الله يعوضك اذا هذا المنزل
فداء فلسطين والقدس يقول راتب اذا هذا
المنزل هو من بين 30 عقارا بحسب الاحصاءات
محافظه القدس تم هدمها منذ بدايه العام اي
خ- خلال اقل من شهر وعلى ذكر عمليات الهدم
او وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي ثمار
بارك لرئيس البلديه الاسرائيليه في القدس
وايضا الشرطه الاسرائيليه سرعه التحرك
والشروع في هدم منازل فلسطينيين في همم
القدس واعتبر كثير ان ذلك يندرج تحت اطار
ما سماهم محاربه الارهاب
الوسائل اذا هذا ما كان هو منزل ياوي
عائله اصبح الان ركاما وبحسب مصادر
اسرائيليه فان هناك عمليات هدم اا قادمه
في الايام القادمه و بانها لن تتوقف عند
منزل راتب شقيرات وجه وقفيه الجزيره جبل
المكبر
في القدس المحتله شكرا لك